c'est très difficile de voir toutes ces
pièces au musée pas seulement d'être 8
mai salle pleine de poussière on a
assisté au son de la destruction du
musée c'était assez impressionnant
une de nos principales sources de
financement maintenant pour la
reconstruction du musée le bâtiment et
la restauration des oeuvres vient du
ministère de la culture français et on
n'a pas reçu un coup de fil une visite
évidemment mais même pas un coup de fil
du ministère la culture libanais ou d'un
représentant de l'état
[Musique]
par rapport aux vitraux on a dû refaire
à l'identique tout tout le motif à
partir de dessins à partie des motifs
que nous avons récupéré au sol et qui a
permis de reconstituer à l'identique
tous les éléments des vitraux
[Musique]
il ya une toile le procureur aux tyrans
qui est très endommagée il y avait
beaucoup de pertes de la couche
picturale et on a envoyé cette oeuvre à
paris au centre pompidou il y aura une
discussion autour de cette oeuvre
comment on va la restaurer
[Musique]